Let's take a look at
the Handshake Protocol.
As we have discussed, the Handshake
Protocol establishes a TLS session.
And it negotiates
the security parameters
between the client and the server.
The phase one of the protocol,
establishes the security capabilities,
it is initiated by the client sending
a client hello message to the server.
The client hello message
contains a number of parameters
including version number,
session ID, crypto suite,
compression method, and
the initial random numbers.
After sending the client a hello
message, the client waits for
the server hello message,
which contains the same kind of
parameters as the client hello message.
Therefore, at the interface one,
both the client and
the server know each other's
security capabilities.
The details of Phase 2 depend on the
underlying public key encryption scheme
that is being used.
In some cases, the server passes
a certificate to the client, and
possibly, some additional key
information and the request for
a certificate from the client.
The final message has
to be server hello done
which indicates the end of phase two.
In phase three, the server should first
verify the certificate of the server.
For example if the client
is connecting to a server
say Georgia Tech's website then
the client should be able to verify
that the certificate contains
the Georgia Tech's public key.
That is, the public key certificate
is Georgia Tech's public key
signed by the public key of
the certificate authority.
And the client has the private
key of the certificate authority
to verify the certificate.
Then the client can send key
exchange information to the server.
For example the client can
generate a secret key and encrypt
the secret key using the server's
public key and send it to the server.
Depending on the application
requirements the client may send
a certificate To the server in order
to authenticate the client to a server.
Usually, if a website is public facing,
then the authentication is usually
one way, that is, the client
needs to authenticate the server.
But the server does not require
the client to authenticate his self.
On the other hand, for internal or
private web servers,
mutual authentication may be required.
In phase two, the client sends
a change cipher spec message and
copies the pending security parameters
to the current cipher spec.
It then signals the completion
of the handshake protocol.
In response, the server sends
its own change_cipher_spec.
Therefore, they now agree
on the security parameters.
And then the server sends its own
message to signal the end of handshake.
At this point, the handshake
is complete and the client and
server can begin to exchange
application layer data protected using
the agreed upon security parameters.